hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in round
11 of our coverage of the 2018 Canada's
tournament there's 14 told around so we
are coming up on the final stretch here
the winner of this tournament does go on
to face Magnus Carlsen we have eight
competitors they play each opponents
twice one with the white pieces one with
the black pieces
Fabiano Cara Juana is in the lead of the
tournament our competitors today Levon
Aronian playing the white pieces he's
not having the tournament he hoped many
thought that he would come in and
actually win at this tournament he's
just been playing so well but he's in
last place but good news for him he has
the white pieces in his opponent Sergei
County akan is the only player that he
has beaten and he beat him with the
black pieces so he has that going for
him
black Sergei cardiac and he won this
tournament two years ago he knows a
thing about winning in what it takes to
finish strong in this tournament and
he's been doing just that winning a
couple of his past few games and knowing
that if he were to win this game he's
only a point behind Fabiana when he
plays Fabiano's tomorrow and he has the
white pieces against Fabiana so he can
tie things up so this game means
everything but it's an uphill battle he
does have the black pieces Levon Aronian
trying to say faced in this tournament
starts out the game with pawns who c4
Knight f6 and Knight f3
then after pawn to e6 that we might see
the pawn to d4 just giving into the
Queen's game at line but instead we see
pawn to g3 extending into the English
opening pawn down here to a d5 Bishop to
g2 fee and Cotto on the kingside pawn to
c4 that's gonna fall Queen to a4 check
and it's gonna gobble up the pawn no
real way to hold on to that
so after pawn to c6 we see the queen
capture on c4 pawn to b5 Queen comes
back to b3 Bishop to a b7 castle on the
King side Bishop e7 getting ready to
castle on the King side as well for
black pawn to d4 so white eventually
getting his upon's in the center
involved into the action castle on the
Kings side
rook here to d1 game involved protecting
this pawn here on a d4 Knight to d7
a knight up here to e5 after the knight
takes the pawn recaptures and white has
double pawns on the e-file he does open
up for his rook here on d1 to attack so
the queen is going to get defended with
a knight here on D 7 bishop up here to
f4 protecting at this pond so white does
have to worry about this pawn here on e5
just because it is a double pawn not as
easy to protect he doesn't want to play
something I mean kid it could always
play something like pawn to f4 it just
really opens up the door for black to
attack so instead plays Bishop here to
f4 now Queen to a c7 does not want to
have to worry about his nights here on
d7 moving in as Queen captures so Queen
here to c7 this Knight is a free now to
roam around if it wants to Knight here
to d2 rook over to ad8 rook here to c1
attacking the semi open file and then
pawn here to a6 and if you look at and
say why does the knight not take here on
e5 well if the knight takes here yes the
Queen is protecting it but we have the
Queen coming up here to b5 and that is
that the key move here is Queen takes
after the pawn takes the works gonna
come up here maybe the bishop comes down
doesn't really matter if these bishops
come off the board all things are
created equal the maybe the bishop takes
first here on e5 both of the bishops
will eventually come off here on g2 but
Bishop down here to be for the rook was
attacking it so if wants to hold on to
that King takes Bishop takes here rook
down here to c5 attacking material and
at the end the day White's going to be
up in the game from a development
standpoint from material standpoint
things are equal but you can clearly see
that this rookie are on a c6 is much
more aggressive than what black has
going so you know Knight to e5 probably
nots what black wants to do there's no
way to come out of the exchange doing
its tremely well and probably best-case
scenario why it's gonna have a very
active rook going into the in-game not
something blacks looking to do so after
pawn to a6 we have the Queen come over
here - III paneer to c5 after the bishop
takes Queen recaptures and then up here
to e4 and then pawn to c4 so kinda Yakka
doing a good job of extending his pawns
and getting pretty aggressive many times
in the English opening you don't see
black get this aggressive but that's
exactly what we are seeing from black on
the Queen side of the board pawn to h4
so white starting to push on the King
side pawn to h6 that need to really stop
it too much just making sure that the
knight the bishop all these pieces can't
come to this g5 square it does protect
that rook coming up here to a d4 Knight
back to f8 and then pawn to b3 and this
is where I think white had an
opportunity to try something else
anytime your opponent's sort of retreats
a piece now Knight to f8 is really just
getting ready for this night to get
involved in a different way
Knight here to g6 / you know attacking
this square here on e5 since it doesn't
have another pawn protecting it but as
soon as you see this White has the
opportunity to attack his opponent he
could play Knight to d6 and yes there
could be an exchange Bishop takes here
on d6 rook takes up here maybe rook
takes pawn recaptures maybe the Queen
comes down here to d5 Queen down here to
d2 but if we look at this position you
can see this Knight is here on f8 s not
really aggressive White has the pawn
here on d6 it's a passed pawn can move
his rook over here to d1 to start to
attack that the rook here on a eights
not doing too much from black now if we
come back in the game and say okay pawns
who b3 allowing black - yes bring his
knight back here to f8 and then do
exactly what karyakin wants to do now
the rook can swing down take the rook
here on a d4 after the Queen takes now
rook to d8 this rook is very active
controlling the D file now yes the
knight can come up to a d6 and there is
going to be an exchange on the board but
after
the pond takes you can see black already
has a much better position his rook is
already on d8 and so now he can play
something like pawns who f6 much better
positioned from black stand point wasn't
even worried too much about this pawn
here on a b3 we do see the bishop come
back here to III pawn to e5 so even
pushing in the center of the board
unfortunately the Queen to come Queen
comes back here to b2 Queen here to c6
so protecting this square in the center
of the board as well as adding another
attacker on the square here on d6
roaning decides to go ahead and take the
pawn here on c4 the pun recaptures and
now black has a passed pawn white also
has a passed pawn but doesn't add a lot
of protection to it right now but that
is why it's main asset that he has going
for him is this pawn here on d6
Black has a pretty active position he
does need to get his knight involved
into the game and then start pushing
this pawn here on the C file one thing
that you will see is a black wants to
maintain this pawn here on a c4 for a
while because his opponent has a dark
square bishop and so both of these pawns
even will stay here so it doesn't have
to worry about another piece attacking
these pawns where the Knights they can
defend any square so you can bring that
over to the Queen side of the board and
defend that and really only have to
worry about the Queen and the rook
something to keep in mind for your own
games Queen comes up here too before
attacking the pawn rook swings over here
to c8 defending the pawn as well pawn up
here to f3 pawn h5 now King to f2 both
sides getting their kings involved to
the game want to keep them safe because
they're both their opponents have their
Queens involved and you can start to
really attack your opponent if you have
the Queen rook over here to a d1 Knight
to d7 just stopping any sort of pushing
from that pawn there on d6 Queen comes
back here to b1 pawn on g6 pushing
forward pawn to g4 rook over here to h8
and just says if you're gonna take I
want to keep my pawn here on g6 so I can
just take with
my rook if I want to but pawn to g5 okay
so starting to push a little bit more
from Levon Aronian pawn to f5 not
interested in exchanging material right
here from Sergei County yeah Kim plays
pawn to f5 Queen up to see two rook
swings back over here CA does not have
to worry about the pawn taking and
retaking with his rook here on the H
file so it brings it back here to c8
queen up to a c3 came down here to e6
does want to protect this pawn here on
e5 this is something Queens attacking
later on this dark square bishop it that
once you can't attack it as well it has
the knight defending it but that's
really the only thing that Knights
really just blocking this pawn secondary
it's defending this pawn here on e5 but
it's not what I have to do that for the
rest of the game King here to a g2 Queen
to a four this is attacking the pawn
here on a two still protecting this pawn
here on c4 but now also attacking the
rook here on a d1 Queen comes back here
to d2 to protect this rook as well as
still a defend the square here on d6 and
then the Queen comes back here to b5
pawn pushes forward on a four then we
see Queen come back here to c6 Queen
here to see two attacking this pawn rook
over here to b8 getting ready for a
strong attack Bishop back here to d2 a
once - just get it in the center of the
board but you can see it's not really
defending either of these squares over
here the pawn here on a6 as well as the
pawn here on a4 and we start to see a
very aggressive move from black great
move and that's the rook coming down
here to b3 the reason why this is good
is the Queen here on c2 is protecting
this pawn this rook here on b3 is
protected by this pawn it's an outpost
you normally don't see an outpost for
rook but considering that there's no
light square bishop that white house
can't attack this rook and there's no
other night that can attack this rook as
well this is a pretty great outpost and
the other thing it does is it blocks
this Queen from protecting this pawn
here on a4 so we see at the pond our
bishop
coming up here to c3 attacking this pawn
here on e5 the Queen takes on a4 so is
gobbling up some material now has
another pass pawn on the a file we're
over here to a a 1 says yeah I'm gonna
attack your Queen and then when you move
I'm gonna attack your pawn here on a6
but the Queen comes back here to c6
which is great to where it's defending
both of these pawns also attacking this
pawn here on d6 rook comes up here to a5
so I'm doubling up the attack on in this
pawn on e5 rook coming up here to b5
protecting that Queen down to a 4 and
then Knight to b6 attacking the Queen
now it would be a huge mistake to just
try to start exchanging you know rook
takes here on a6 the Knights going to
take the Queen maybe the rook takes here
on a c6 but the problem is the knight
can take the bishop here on c3 if the
bishop wasn't here on c3 this could end
up being a decent exchange but rook
takes on c4 Knight takes on e too and
things are gonna go extremely bad it's
gonna be very easy for black to take
this pawn here on d6 and then just has
more pawns on the board as well as an
extra minor piece so while I may look at
it and say yeah we'll just go ahead and
you know start exchanging material that
is not going to be the case so after the
knight comes to b6 we do see the queen
fall back to a1 now a cardiac in takes
the rook here on a5 recognizing that he
is up material and he just wants to
trade down as much as possible Queen
takes to that rook here on a5 Queen
comes down here to b5 says yeah just go
ahead and and take my queen if you want
to because I'm gonna have to pass pawns
over here this is gonna be a pretty easy
in game for me but instead we see pawns
who d7 giving up that pawn immaterial
King takes here on d7 sure yes the
bishop was able to take this pawn here
on e5 at some point but did give up the
main asset that white had going for him
there on a d7 so after Queen to a3 we
see the knight coming to d5 Bishop takes
here on e5 getting some material back
but
Queens to c6 now defending both of these
ponds both on light squares and even the
night here on d5 Black's done a good job
of putting every single material piece
of material on a light squared there's
not one pond or piece that this dark
square Bishop can attack definitely a a
thought that cardiac can has in his mind
making sure that he can minimize the
pieces and the damage they can do so the
only thing that Levon Aronian can do is
get his queen involved into the game
start to attack with that so Queen to f8
Queen over here to e6 Queen to a b8 pawn
to c3 so yes it is now on a dark square
but is protected by the Knights doesn't
want to add pressure to his opponent so
pawn to c3 Queen down here to a b7 check
King here to e8 and then the King's just
gonna try to get to a safe square Queen
here to b7 now Knight up to e7 this does
force black to bring his knight here and
the queen or the the bishop is able to
take the pawn if he wants to so after
the bishop takes the Queen comes down
here to e2 check King here to h3 and
then the Queen back to be 5 so this
Lulu's one of the past pawns
that's completely ok though still has
the passed pawn here on the a file and
is able to push that one now but brings
it over here to b5 says hey if you want
to trade off this is gonna be completely
fine with me as you can imagine that's
not what white is killing for he would
clearly lose that place Queen here to c7
a queen to c6 just say hey let's go
ahead and trade off but nope we don't
see that instead Queen here to e5 if we
see something else cuz this Queen here
on c6 is attacking this pawn on f3 and
is gonna gobble that material up but
it's so tough for what White's looking
to do you know how does he continue to
maintain control of this pawn in f3 if
he comes back to 8 okay yeah that still
attacks this pawn and defends this
square here but now all of a sudden
Queens who f1 check after the Queen
moves then Queens who F
- and there's no great square he can
just gobble up this material here on h1
so no great places for for white to go
to so in the game decides yeah I'll just
go ahead and play Queen here to see
seven after the Queen to see six comes
down to e5 and the pawn is captured King
moves Queen down here to f2 after the
King moves to h1 then just starts
gobbling out material you can see
there's just no way for white to hold on
here he's just losing so much material
he just can't stop all of the threats
that black has on the board King here to
g1 the Queen takes here on a g5 check
King here to h2 we see a few more checks
and then eventually why it starts to go
on the attack just doesn't have enough
material to really continue to much the
Queen comes up there to g7 check King
here to e6 just trying to get to a safe
square Bishop to f6 Knight down to d5
centralizing the Knights Bishop down
here to b2 and then starting pushing on
the King side with the pawns and this is
where there's just no way to stop all of
the threats from both side key here to
h2 then we see the King to f5 probably
should have just continued to push
forward don't think there's any reason
to play King to f5 completely winning in
the game but it does look like just
pushing forward with f3 is gonna be
completely fine but in the game King to
f5 Queen to f8 we see the King come over
here to a g5 White has to continue his
attack with his queen as much as
possible Queen to d8 check King down
here to g4 Queen CA check King over here
to h4 Bishop down to g7 so this gives an
opportunity for black to now starting
attack now that he's not being checked
by his opponent Queen down here to e2
King to h1 and now things there's no way
to stop this and he he had very few
checks that he could continue early on
but now he's in a mating pattern Queen
here to f3 King here to h2 and now Queen
to g3 and after this
white decided to resign some people
always ask how this could continue maybe
King 2h one Queen down here II won pawn
to f3 check if they scaled up that's
fine Queens who III check Knight to f4
check and then eventually it is going to
be checkmates with the Queen here so at
the end of the day surrogate karyakin
with the black pieces losses earlier
with the white pieces against the mana
Ronin the only game that vonroenn II is
one now he comes back he recognizes the
stakes he says I need to get a win with
the black pieces to get my shell myself
a shot going into tomorrow against
Fabiana Caruana
and i had the white pieces against him
I'm a point down and that's exactly what
he did so congratulations he was
extremely aggressive his black against
the English opening at the end of day it
paid off played a phenomenal in game
with both Queens on the board I felt
like he always made the correct decision
put his opponent in some tough spots and
then utilized his rook over here on the
beef I'll bring you down here to b3 to
start an attack gobble up one of the
ponds and then continue from there to
push to a victory so Levon Aronian
again in last place not having the
tournament that he wants but tomorrow is
gonna be some fireworks we have three
games left in this tournament and
there's a lot of people up at the top
looking for the title here
Fabiano Caruana can really extend his
lead here
going against in third place right now
Sergei County yakin so hopefully you
guys are enjoying the tournament so far
we have we'll have more coverage in the
next round but thanks for watching I'll
see you guys then